placez la solitude nos parce qu'on on
est à la maison un peu plus souvent en
télétravail notamment que ça donne plus
de temps a fait pour s'occuper des
animaux sur certaines ya des refuges du
québec qui ont marqué une hausse des
adoptions d'animaux de compagnie depuis
le début de la pandémie j'en parle avec
elle à d'éternelles caroline picard
bonjour alain picard alors les refuges
pour animaux constate vraiment des
hausses d adoption plus d'adoption c'est
ce qu'on m'a confirmé du moins à la
spéciale de montréal c'est sûr que c'est
des données qui sont pas faciles à
compiler parce qu'il n'y a pas seulement
d adoption au niveau des lois fusent
mais aussi auprès les îles par tout ce
qui est petit annonces classées aussi
vous est ce que les gens peuvent se
procurer des animaux et on remarque même
dans nos facebook à des gens qu'on
connaît des amis qui on présente le
nouveau venu à la maison soit le chat ou
le chien qu'est ce qui explique cette
hausse selon vous mais je pense que les
gens ont chacun des motifs personnels
pour adopter le fait de passer plus de
temps la maison certains d'entre eux
pensaient pour c'est le moment idéal de
parfaire l'éducation d'un chien ou d'un
chaton parce que je veux être présent
regarder d'autres calmants pour combler
la solitude ou accomplir un manque à ce
niveau là toute l'espèce aux
thérapeutiques ou si la présence d'un
animal pour des personnes qui passent
beaucoup de temps à domicile est aussi
une proportion des gens qui vont
simplement plus tout s'offrir comme
famille d'accueil
parce que eux ont une sensibilité qu'au
point de vue des refuges à cause qui y
travaillent avec un effectif qui est
réduit et ont besoin les refuges de
placer le plus possible des animaux en
dehors de leurs locaux ou pouvant leur
permettrait d'abord que d'activité ils
ont un bon et vous comme de terreur vous
avez quand même constaté des effets de
la pandémie en plus de temps avec
l'animal ça permet peut-être des fois de
découvrir des petits bobos hanche et
notre chien notre chat qu'on n'avait pas
vu
il ya des gens qui vont voix pour ça
laisse aucun feeling bernard on a manqué
vraiment une hausse de demande de
consultation surtout pour des problèmes
chroniques et ça commence à être un peu
difficile parfois suffire à la demande
parce que aussi en clinique vétérinaire
ont fait face avec des effectifs réduits
de personnel réduit alors on se doit de
faire un peu un triage on va favoriser
toujours les consultations pour des
problèmes médicaux ou pour les personnes
par exemple qui ont adopté un jeune
chaton un jeune chien dont l'immunité
les points encore complétée d'un point
de vue vaccination ballon doit pour ces
animaux là les prenant cliniques les
soirs que les chiots et les chatons
cartons jaunes ont souvent besoin de
deux à trois consultations des dernières
à un mois d'intervalle
donc là aussi ça vient petit peu saturé
les plages horaires disponibles un pied
nique
alors si on se procure chaque enchère
d'importance justement de prendre ça en
considération
est-ce que la pandémie le confinement le
fait d'être beaucoup à la maison avec
nos animaux aura des conséquences
négatives pour certains animaux de
compagnie lorsque par exemple on va
reprendre une vie normale ou
effectivement j'ai vu en clinique
détonnant de plus en plus des gens qui
demandent conseil à ce niveau là on part
que l'animal développe de l'anxiété de
séparation
donc on essaye beaucoup de les
accompagner de trouver des astuces pour
pouvoir faire une transition entre le
mode de vie en télétravail qu'ils
avaient et le retour au travail
c'est complexe assure que ce problème la
blonde s'était de séparation en tant qu'
on n'a pas un animal qui le vit ça
devient un peu difficile à cerner là où
était vraiment du coup par coup pour ce
qu'il n'acceptait de libération comment
ça se présente cette anxiété de
séparation en général mais l'animal il
pourrait émettre c'est par exemple lui
seul de vocalises pourrait premier
davantage dans les logements pour faire
des dégâts aussi
alors si c'est ce genre de signes lac
nous permettent de croire que notre
animal souvenant que c'était de
séparation que tu as quelques conseils
madame picard pour ces gens qui ont
passé beaucoup de temps la maison avec
leurs animaux et qui vont bientôt
reprendre peut-être retourner au travail
physiquement comment on prépare notre
animal au fait qu'on soit pas tout le
temps avec l'humain mais je pense que
c'est important avant le retour au
travail de juste établir une routine
pour l'animal donc un peu de prévoir
qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir offrir à
l'allemagne une fois qu'on va être de
retour au travail que ce soit les
sorties sorties matin sortie le soir et
aussi maillot toujours tous les produits
naturels tu peuvent être utilisés des
phéromones compliqué dans la maison au
moment du départ juste pour calmer
l'animal signalements dont on a besoin
et bien car les piquants merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous vaut quelques
conseils ce matin après plaisir magione